Multiplica y simplifica,
5 raíz cúbica de "2x" cuadrada,
por 3 raíz cúbica de "4x" cuarta.
Y aquí hay dos cosas que se me ocurren,
por un lado la multiplicación es conmutativa,
es decir,  podemos invertir
el orden los factores, con lo cual,
las constantes podríamos multiplicarlas primero,
podríamos multiplicar 5 por 3,
lo otro que se me ocurre, es que estos dos términos,
los estamos elevando a la raíz cúbica
y elevada a la raíz cúbica es elevar a la un tercio,
es decir, raíz cúbica de "x"
es igual a "x" elevada a la un tercio.
Hagamos eso, invirtamos el orden
y reescribamos estas raíces cúbicas,
como si estudian elevadas a la potencia un tercio.
Tenemos entonces el 5 y el 3,
que estamos multiplicando 5 por 3
y luego tenemos la raíz cúbica de "2x" cuadrada
déjame hacerlo con otro color mejor...
la raíz cúbica de "2x" cuadrada que la podemos escribir como
"2x" cuadrada elevada a la un tercio
multiplicando a la raíz cúbica de "4x" cuarta...
"4x" cuarta elevada a la un tercio.
Ahora sabemos
por las propiedades de los exponentes,
que si tenemos el producto de dos cosas que están elevadas a la misma potencia,
podemos tomar primero el producto
y luego elevarlo a la potencia,
es decir, si tengo "a"
elevada a la potencia "x",
por "b" elevada a la potencia "x"
esto es lo mismo que
"a" por "b" elevado a la potencia "x",
así es que esta parte de aquí,
la podemos reescribir
como
2x cuadrada
por "4x" cuarta,
todo eso elevado a la un tercio
y por supuesto 5 por 3 es igual a 15.
Y ahora,
esta expresión de aquí,
es un producto, es conmutativo,
ya hemos mencionado eso
y también es asociativo,
no importa el orden en el que hacemos las operaciones.
Entonces esto de aquí lo puedo simplificar como
2 por 4...
esto es igual a 6...
y "x" cuadrada por "x" cuarta
esto es igual a "x" a la sexta
y todo eso
elevado a la un tercio
y esto multiplicado por...
pero perdón, aquí tengo un error...
discúlpame...
2 por 4 no es 6,
2 por 4 es 8
y luego "x" cuadrada por "x" cuarta,
es "x" la sexta,
x a la sexta...
sí, creo que estaba
sumando estos exponentes
por eso decía que 2 por 4 era 6,
pero no, es 8
y aquí al sumar estos exponentes
para dar "x" a la sexta.
Mi cerebro no funcionó bien ahí,
así es que esto es
"8x" sexta elevado a la un tercio
y todo esto multiplicado por 15.
Que ahora,
podemos usar esta misma propiedad,
bueno,
no exactamente esta misma propiedad,
no... sí sí sí sí sí...
esta misma propiedad,
pero el sentido inverso,
la usamos de la siguiente manera,
8 por "x" a la sexta elevado a la un tercio,
es igual a 8 elevado a la un tercio,
por "x" a la sexta, elevada a la un tercio,
y todo esto multiplicado...
todo esto multiplicado por 15.
Ahora 8 a la un tercio,
es lo mismo que raíz cúbica de 8,
y como 8 es igual a 2 por 2 por 2,
es decir, 2 al cubo,
la raíz cúbica de 2 al cubo es,
2 al exponente 1,
simplemente 2
y "x" a la sexta, elevada al un tercio,
bueno,
aplicando las propiedades de los exponentes,
esto lo mismo que "x" elevado a las 6 por un tercio...
6 por un tercio es 2...
Así es que esto de aquí,
es equivalente a "x" cuadrada.
¿Qué tenemos entonces?
15 por 2...
15 por 2 es 30
este término aquí es 30,
lo cual multiplica a...
déjame hacerlo con otro color...
multiplica a...
no es en este otro color...
que multiplica a
"x" cuadrada.
Hemos terminado,
hay varias maneras en que podías haber hecho esto.
Podrías no haber usado la anotación de exponentes aquí.
Podrías decir bueno, aquí tengo la raíz cúbica de esto,
la raíz cúbica de esto,
como la raíz cúbica del producto
y entonces en vez de este exponente tengo aquí,
una raíz cúbica y dependiendo de cómo lo agrupe,
podría hacer esto en distinto orden
mientras uses las propiedades
adecuadas de los exponentes,
deberás de llegar aquí...
deberás de obtener esta misma respuesta.